[Music]
thank you
Douglas for the cover piece this week
you have written about the culture wars
infiltrating museums what's been
happening
well I start off with a description of
going to the Pitt Rivers Museum in
Oxford this past week the Pitt Rivers
museum has always been an interesting
Oddity of a museum a collection of of
many 19th century collected artifacts
it's
um it was a place famed among other
things for the Pickled heads that it had
in it and even as an undergraduate more
than 20 years ago now it was it was it
was known of us being an oddity but an
oddity from another time
um and I discovered on returning this
week that it's now become an oddity of
our own time
uh the museum is filled with
condemnations of the museum The
Collection is filled with condemnations
of the collection almost everything
tells you about the sins of European
colonialism European racism there are of
course all of the nods to the religion
of our time there are segments on beyond
the binary because I'm sure that's what
everybody wants when they go to the pit
Rivers collection and we see for
instance anime characters from the 1990s
show a strong queer icons my point is
that the museum is effectively
abolishing itself it's saying that the
collection was put together by bad
forces and it has to be saved in the
modern era reinterpreted and indeed
accused now this as I say in my cover
piece this week is not at all unusual it
is something that is going on the
collection after collection of Museum
and Museum after museum across the land
and the Oddity of this is not just that
this is in fact encouraged by for
instance the Museum's Association which
which tells collections in your in the
UK how to quote decolonize but of course
that the collections themselves are
doing it we just saw last weekend the
welcome collection of London's Houston
Road announcing that it was closing its
exhibition why because it had tried to
decolonize but it couldn't tear itself
away from its dead white male Origins
and so the welcome collection announced
that it would be closing it couldn't
justify itself so in the end it stopped
Ed you've read Douglas's piece what did
she make into his Deep dive of what's
happening in museums and the collections
that are present there
well I've got a huge problem uh with
Douglas's piece which is that I agreed
with quite a lot of it so it's going to
be quite hard to have an argument I
think if one unpacks it I mean Douglas
has used
some pretty forceful examples to make
his point as you would expect from uh
one of the country's most successful
columnists and I being a sort of bland
neutral slightly flabby figure uh sit
somewhere in the Midland this which is
that I get engaged in the culture wars
because I think to a certain extent both
sides take rather extreme positions I
think that it is in the 21st century
perfectly possible to look at a museum
collection uh that was a crude say in
the 19th uh Century or the 18th century
and say how did this Museum come by
these objects were they
taken fairly purchased in good faith and
transported back to the UK or were they
looted by British soldiers and if they
were is that something that we should
consider when we put these things on
display and one of the reasons I get
asked onto programs like this is because
I'm in favor of returning the Parthenon
sculptures the default position which to
a certain extent to coin a phrase every
Schoolboy learns is that Lord Elgin
saved the Parthenon sculptures and they
would have been blown up by these
feckless or been allowed to be blown up
by these factors Greeks if Lord Elgin
hadn't intervened I don't think that's
an accurate depiction at all about how
the Parthenon sculptures came to be in
London and even if it was I think now in
the 21st century a perfectly reasonable
request from the Greek government to
potentially have them back should be
considered
um in a sensible way but I do think as
well and this is where Douglas May well
disagree with me so we'll get some juice
out of this uh that it is worth thinking
about cultural seven sensitivities in
the 21st century I mean he cites the Rex
Whistler mural at Tate now I wasn't a
trustee of tape when the trustees made
the decision to close the restaurant
because the images of uh in the mural
were deemed to be offensive but I
respect their decision it wasn't taken
lightly it was thoroughly uh examined
and I'm afraid it is the case that in
the 21st century a lot of people
wandering into the restaurant and seeing
Rex whistler's mural regardless of the
context would find those figures
offensive and it was on the table to
have an explainer or whatever about why
those Figures were there but it was
considered very carefully and I I
support that this is the key point I
support trustees looking at these issues
and making decisions on that basis but
he I fully concede to a certain extent
and indeed I have trolled my own museum
Tate sometimes the labels go completely
over the top and are bordering on the
ridiculous
um let me just if I may pick up on two
things there first of all what I'm
writing about is a different issue than
dxession de-accession is its own issue
at the moment I think we would disagree
on the argument marbles but de-accession
of course has already led to its own
types of lunacy such as for instance the
belief that all bronzes from Benin must
be handed back this came to the extent
that uh two a couple of years ago after
the summer of George Floyd Lambeth
Palace got rid of tubing in bronzes
handed them back to Benin when in fact
these bronzes were gifts to Ronald
runtsy the Archbishop of Canterbury who
has it happened uh christened me as a
boy
um they were given him the 1980s and he
handed them back as if his successors
rather Lambeth Palace handed them back a
couple of years ago as if they were
holding on to a set of stolen Hot
televisions secondly what uh Ed vasey
mentions about uh I'm glad he says that
I use strong examples in my piece and
I'm sure he'd expect that there's no
point in writing and using weak examples
but the example of take Britain
um I think with all due respect it is
entirely wrong about the Tate trustees
took action with extraordinary levity
the trustees of the Tate are ignoramuses
to a man and a woman
every single one of them and let me
explain briefly why the Rex Whistler
mural was commissioned in the 1920s it
includes two tiny figures of black
children clearly in distress being
pulled by women in frilly frocks
laughing it's clearly as any scholar or
fan of Rex Whistler knows something he
does in all of his murals which is to
say it in Arcadia ego this is a a
Fantastical idyllic scene in which he
deliberately across all four walls puts
in tiny details to say even in this
alleged Paradise the worm of human evil
exists the trustees of the Tate did not
consider this who they listened to were
two activists on Instagram from a group
called White pube white pubes the slogan
is F the police F the UK F the Tate now
I don't need to tell Lord vasey F the
Tate is not a chance you often hear on
the streets of London most people don't
have that strong views on tape Britain
this was a malevolent tiny group of
activists who decided to defame Rex
Whistler the trustees of the Tate far
from looking into this immediately got
scared they closed the room they took
Rex whistler's name off it they defamed
him first of all as a racist and then
put up a sign saying that he had the
racist views of his time why do I mind
this not just because the Tate is meant
to house and look after one of our great
collections but because Rex Whistler
died childless fighting on his first day
in Normandy in 1944 how dare one of the
great collections of the UK be in the
hands of people who would defame as a
racist somebody who joined up on the
first weeks of the war in 1939 and laid
down his life fighting Nazism these
people are not looking at these things
carefully any more than they have the
example of Stanley Spencer who they've
also decided to defend in their
collection as a racist these collections
are in the hands of people who are
Unworthy of the things in their care Ed
I think that is I think now Douglas has
slightly descended into caricature I
mean I wasn't a trustee of take when
this decision uh was made but the idea
that uh Tate would make a decision to
close this restaurant uh and uh remove
the mural which they haven't done by the
way uh
somebody had put up an Instagram two
activists to put up an Instagram post uh
is absolutely laughable and I see
nothing wrong with museums first of all
thinking hard about how a collection is
viewed by an audience in the 21st
century as opposed to an audience that
visits uh in the 19th century and that
could include uh the shrunken heads at
the pit Rivers Museum and I think it's
perfectly uh in order for museums to put
in context how objects were acquired by
that collection and in fact the context
of the time in which they were acquired
so I see uh absolutely no problem uh
with that at all and I think so I think
that it's it's uh the idea that you
wouldn't modernize your displays and
your collections and put them in context
in the 21st century I think is uh
laughable the idea is that our Museum
should kind of sit in aspic and be
exactly as our Victorian forefathers uh
visited them before uh seems to me
laughable I'd like to ask you each a
question to challenge your perspectives
um and Douglas to you first this point
about context is important isn't it
um putting aside some of the more
extreme examples where they've just
decided to shut down collections would
you have an issue with curators deciding
that rather than shutting things down
they would like to give a modern context
and they would like to give more
information to those visiting the museum
I mean presumably that is their remit of
course so that people really understand
what they're consuming and perhaps some
of the atrocities behind what they're
consuming
oh yes absolutely by the way Ed Rosie
sets up as a tall man as politicians of
his kind always do not nothing you would
ever do Douglas no I don't need to
believe me I don't need to
um he sets up a straw man by pretending
that I or anyone like me thinks that we
should preserve our Collections and
aspic I don't believe that at all I
think that trustees obviously always
have to reinvigorate and renew
collections what I think is strange is
that they should hate the collections
which they are in charge of again I come
back to the point I followed unlike Ed
extremely closely the activities that
they take in recent years and also
observed extremely closely the way in
which they decided to make Stanley
Spencer one of the other two great
artists of the 20th century in their
collection into a posthumous racist for
no good reason at all so yes that's what
I find strange but to get back to your
point Kate the interesting thing about
this were retain and explain thing is
it's absolutely fine and admirable so
long as it isn't a one directional
political hit job and let me give you an
example of what a one-directional
political hit job looks like if you want
to for instance say parts of this museum
were put together by in an era of
colonialism in Europe or colonialism in
Britain fine who doesn't mind that I
don't mind that I don't think anyone
would mind that but here's what I mind
is when you for instance as at the pit
Rivers get that and then a strange
silence on everywhere else in the world
for instance the kingdom of Benin which
has already come up a couple of times if
you stand before the display on the
kingdom of Benin in the pit Rivers
Museum in Oxford do you learn anything
about slavery curiously enough no do you
learn that the kingdom of Benin was
practicing slavery long after the
British Empire decided to abolish it and
sent its ships across the seas trying to
stamp it out anywhere else no and you
would leave believing that the rest of
the planet lived in Eden until the
wicked Europeans arrive it's not
education it's self-flagellation
I think that uh without wishing to
descend into cliche two wrongs uh don't
make uh a right and um it is set to us
to put into context the collections that
we have in this country and how they
were Acquired and 99 of them were
acquired uh perfectly uh legitimately
and it's a great thing as well that we
have these British institutions that
display uh an extraordinary range of
artifacts and paintings from all over uh
the world but I think when the Benin
bronzes were looted uh that we should
own up to that fact and think about
returning but Ed some of the Benin
bronzes were given to this country by
the prime minister of Nigeria after
Independence what do we do with those
uh well I mean I'm not gonna I don't
know enough about Robert Francis
you haven't thought about it enough but
if he uh if uh if they require
legitimately you know it's a matter of a
Lambert Palace if they were if they're
their possessions what they what they
wish to uh what they wish to do with
them and I have two contributions for
you Ed first is
um do we not Risk by removing so-called
offensive artwork
um losing parts of History losing those
uncomfortable offensive parts of History
uh do we not risk
suggesting that these things never
happened at all and actually to a more
fundamental point about offense as well
since when is it wrong for art or great
works of literature to be offensive to
challenge us for us to be uncomfortable
with what we see if we decide that such
works are too risky for people to be
exposed to what are we going to be
looking at when we go into museums
what's going to be there to challenge us
I think it's a very fair Challenge and I
think it's a very nuanced debate and to
a certain extent you should do it um
object by object I think as I say I
wasn't a trustee when uh the Tate
trustee is considered the Rex Whistler
mural but they clearly took the view
that these were effectively racial
character chores and no uh attempt to
put them in context or whatever would
necessarily reduce the offense that a
modern 21st century audience whether
it's black or white would feel when they
were coming in to have a nice lunch at
Tate so they've taken that decision and
I think you know what I want to get
across there I think Douglas is to be
frank being very very unfair to think
that this was a sort of decision taken
uh you know in a nanosecond um I'm being
wired over a couple of um digestive
biscuits and a cup of tea I think it was
thought through very carefully over very
early can I ask everybody thinks about
the Stanley Spencer
trustees can I ask Ed what he thinks
about it as far as I'm aware Stanley
Spencer is still on full display at Tate
Britain and is not called a racist in by
Tate or anyone else I can assure you can
look this is very important with a
former Arts Minister because you have to
be on top of these things I'm sorry but
as with the Benin brontes you have to be
on top of this
you know the ornament museum has just
returned the men in bronzes to Nigeria
Nigeria hasn't thrown off his hands in
horror and said you shouldn't return
these you've got them perfectly
legitimately and I'm on top of Stanley
Spencer in the sense and I say Stanley
Spencer remains on full display at Tate
and it's not called a racist
yes he is
go down there today if you have the time
and you will see that his Masterpiece
the resurrection at cookham in in the
accompanying description as I say in my
piece claims that Stanley Spencer used
racialized images of black people now it
doesn't bother to say that in this
extraordinary Masterpiece as I'm sure
you'll agree it is if you know the
painting in this extraordinary
Masterpiece that displays the the
resurrection of the Dead on the day of
judgment in Stanley Spencer's Church
nearby churchyard in cookham it shows
people of all Races emerging from the
ground
uh you know calling somebody a racist
that is not calling him a racist go back
to the quote I give him the piece as
with Rex Whistler they look at the work
in their in their truck in their care
with the most hostile lens imaginable
there was nobody black in cookham in the
1920s
please let me finish finish your point
Ed response I'm going to ask one more
question and then we're going to wrap up
because we're well over time Douglas you
have 30 seconds
a reasonable estimation of the Spencer
painting in the Tate is that because
there was nobody black and cook them at
the time if you wanted to show the
resurrection of all of humanity yes he
relied on photographs from National
Geographic does that make him a racist
obviously not is it what he has impuned
as being by Tate yes it's right by the
painter I don't agree that's the case at
all
we'll go down and see it to Ed and
Douglas uh add to you first do you think
that the way in which museums are now
curated and the way that art is
presented to us has become too
politicized or do you think that the
interventions that are taking place now
are crucial to a modern understanding of
what happened in the past
well I started this uh debate by saying
that I agreed with a lot of uh what
Douglas wrote in his article as I say I
think that the extreme positions are
taken on uh both sides and I think that
on one side questioning or uh referring
to the fact that you know some objects
were acquired in by GBS means Were
Somehow being unpatriotic and unbritish
or as Douglas is uh in terms of working
himself up just now you know that we're
going around calling Stanley Spencer a
racist I think is ludicrous but at the
same time I do accept that there are
plenty of examples in our museums at the
moment where people have taken it to the
other extreme and there are kind of
gratuitous labels and narratives that
don't really fit you know I am quite
woke on these issues I mean I see
nothing wrong for example in terms of
gcses and a levels in extending uh the
English literature curriculum towards
world uh literature I don't see anything
wrong with those kind of things and
people foam at the mouth if you dare to
suggest that children children British
schools might study authors who weren't
born and bred in Britain and wrote from
outside so I see nothing wrong with
looking at our curriculum looking at our
the objects in museums putting them in
context and extending the range
of objects that people see and uh
re-imagining the narrative Douglas 21
extensioned politics feature in museum
curation and to what extent is it
inevitable I mean ultimately the people
making these decisions will come with
not a neutral point of view and and
you're always going to have some lens
put on what is presented to you
um the job of Trustees of a collection
is to ensure the continuation of the
collection is to know that it is in your
hands for your generation to pass on to
the next one I say in the piece how
extraordinary it is that so much of what
I described has gone on under a
conservative government and I think Lord
vasey has just demonstrated why and how
it is please call me in but but as I say
I think that essentially what we have is
the National Heritage is to a great
extent in the hands of people who don't
much care for it even in one famous
essay and spectator reviewing Stephen
spender's Memoir said that that reading
Stephen Spender in mangling the English
language was like watching a very
valuable vars in the hands of a
chimpanzee
um watching our national Collections and
their trustees and curators at the
moment is like seeing all the most
precious things in our culture in the
hands of chimpanzees they are utterly
for the task they had been appointed to
Adam Douglas thanks for joining me
[Music]